[Music]
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite the heart soul of
this very Beach come on feet make my
passions a little bigger and don't cover
up my front bump you got it huge dick
big dick we're staring into the abyss
here it's up to us restore the Baywatch
brand hey One Direction here for the
qualifiers I'm Matt Brody I don't have
to try out I've got two gold medals hey
Brody yes we still don't get training
begins at oh six hundred is nothing you
would see these people in refrigerators
very watch what is that you think we do
here prevent people from getting
sunburned occasionally stop them from
drowning
stop it I can't save you if you're vegan
dick this is a guy you think it's a good
PR opportunity for us look I get it
you're being sasquatch I'm fast whoa
[ __ ] and touching you suck drugs murder
dead body on our Beach and it all
started once she took over some people
are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best the truth is one of you will
probably die yeah what no the only one
that thinks this is clearly a job for
the police
Thank You blue eye demon you got one job
make sure swim happy white people don't
drown so I just always look like she's
running in slo-mo
she's the reason I believe in God
we gotta go undercover
yeah undercover yeah little 200 cover
oceanic
Jason Bourne ain't got [ __ ] on me
why are we in a morgue you got to get
some hard evidence what's coming what
are you now shall we hide weird I
playing on a dead old lady your drawers
are empty why'd you pick that drawer top
industry it's just a little dead man's
fat no chronic liquid fat then will you
stop being a baby mm-hmm
that's it I'm out
I don't come on brother why did she was
look like she's running in some house
you see you going night-night where you
do this Hey